[Music]
oh i have a really interesting story
here
where it's okay so there are three
adults
involved okay there's lindsay who's 35
there is chris who's 38
and then there's mike who's 52. okay
so lindsay and chris they are
they were married they were married for
six years
they ended up having two kids a boy and
a girl
the little boy is he has an autoimmune
disease so he got really sick
so they've been dealing with that um but
then they got divorced right
so then after they got divorced lindsay
met mike and then they fell in love they
married
they ended up having a baby boy together
okay
well uh at one point lindsay and mike
were they moved into this apartment and
they didn't know that this apartment was
under foreclosure so then they had to be
forced to move out
and then that's when chris was like just
come live with me
i got a five bedroom home like you know
like you and your new husband just come
yes oh [ __ ] we're with the kids so all
three kids now
yeah weird white people are friendly
are they white they're from connecticut
oh yes yes they're like a white ass
story to me
yeah so here oh that is here are the
characters lindsay
chris mike her ex-husband is now living
with her current husband which one's the
ex-husband well the current husband
moved in with the ex-husband
wait x is older than the new yeah cause
he was 52 right 52
38. i know oh whoops wow
whoa oh she upgraded
[ __ ] 38 year old go lindsay old yeah
lindsay's journey yeah lindsay
and then what that's crazy that is crazy
wait so the new boyfriend is 52
yes oh okay i got it the new husband the
okay i got it all [ __ ] up and that's
52. the new husband is 52 but he's the
younger looking yeah i know what the
[ __ ] i know
my mind is [ __ ] blowing me yeah i
know i even looked at
multiple sources and i'm like wait are
you sure this is the new guy he's the
one he's the one white person that aged
well
[Laughter]
[Applause]
lizzie looks good all right lindsay
loves you
she actually looks her age right right
yeah yeah so then
um so yeah so then they all moved in to
chris's home
and so now like the the kids are
together like with parents
and then also lindsay she has a 19 year
old daughter from another marriage damn
she's got a lot
of boys she's she's only three her eggs
are
she's potent she's potent moving into
the 19 year old
so yes the 19 year old also lives in the
same pool hey that's a big viking family
yeah they live in one long house seven
people and that's the 19 year old right
there that she's holding
the age is all messed up
she got the benjamin button thing you
know so okay
so this is
[Laughter]
yeah so so these are the parents of this
i'm sure that's the 52 year old on the
top right yeah
i told you well it looks like they're
together they're like they're close by
each other
this picture you can see something
different than the
well listen mike is looking good and
that we know oh my god what is that
so then girl they're children
so this is the baby for with the new the
new husband these are the two from
the second husband i guess yeah and then
here holy so mike actually has two
older kids that don't live with them and
so what
it's six kids total between all of them
but the two older ones don't live in the
house it's just the four kids in this
one home
they are very um what's the word
they're busy they're like baby factories
yeah so they're saying that everything
that they've done
and the fact that they all live together
is for the kids
and uh and that it works out pretty well
in the beginning it was really
awkward especially for mike mike had the
the hardest time
coping with this all which is the new
husband because it kind of takes away
your manhood
that's exactly what i know what that
meant yeah well cause michael mike
probably offered
out of courtesy you know in politeness
and no chris chris
mike isn't here i'm still wrapping my
brain mike's a new guy yeah
so mike is the one that said mike come
live with me no no
that's chris so chris doesn't have a
woman in his life just to clear
clarify everything he's trying to get
back at you drop the names that's what's
[ __ ] me up drop the names old guy new
guy
new guy new guy new guy's older
that's right
oh god third so where's first husband
he's not in the picture okay
the second husband the second husband
was born first though that's the
spin-off i want to know
okay very confusing and then also the
because i listened to the podcast that
they got interviewed oh on how many
microphones they have in the box
quite a lot and in the podcast lindsay
was saying how she met chris
chris remember the the second husband
here so
she was saying that when she met chris
that one month after meeting they moved
in together
one month one month after that they got
married wow that's
fast they'd be doing that in connecticut
but then they they stay together for six
years
and then she said that she just kind of
fell out of love with him and she just
felt more like he was
like a best friend roommate he got that
face
yeah the brother zone he got brother
zoned that brother's on face
he's got that face okay first of all
identical this son looks exactly like
him yeah yeah
he's got the hair and everything look at
this yeah
yeah true and the new baby's pissed in
every picture
you brought me into this [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it's like i don't know
[Laughter]
okay so mike has four kids now okay so
mike has three kids because it's two
from a previous relationship and one
with
angry baby yeah angry baby chris
has three no two kids no wait yes two
kids
okay yeah lindsay has four kids
total guys no she has
six oh of her four kids of her own
vagina mike's
the other two yeah she had a 19 year old
wait where's a 19 year old
a diagram we i'm so confused man
the other ones are mike's kids why does
mike look 19. like how does he do i know
mike looks so young i got it that's the
whole family right this is my
someone's missing two people are missing
yeah no one they're babies
one of their daughters the baby's over
here trying to and there's like
19 year olds missing here no the 19 year
old is one of these two girls
there's three little ones the little
girl missing yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're using the baby to prop up the
timer
yeah so interesting well hey good for
them situation
that they could make it work and make it
uh that's awesome one big happy family i
feel like that is something that like
happens in connecticut okay i i figured
out who's missing here it is the baby
and it's in her belly
oh so this is crazy oh okay it's right
before that so it hasn't been knit
popping i actually figured but i didn't
want to assume
yeah i'm assuming
but yeah so then okay so you know how i
said that chris
invited them into his oh there's more oh
my god a little bit more
like he invited them into his home and
then they
ended up getting into a situation i
don't know the situation but
eventually it evolved to the point where
they
bought a home together so all three whoa
have purchased the home together and so
now they're all like
three homeowners there and so they're
really kind of like doubling down on the
situation
co-parenting let's pull our resources
together that's kind of cool
but only lindsay and mike are having sex
no chris kristen might too can they do a
little three-way
yeah yeah yeah lindsay and mike are
having so no one else is having sex
that's [ __ ] up
well and then so i hope the kids aren't
no
no the 19 year old this is a 19 year old
yeah there's nice
so no no no no don't don't go there
tiff calm yourself
so i thought i thought we just had the
lunch
no but yeah so then uh they were talking
on the interview in the interview
they were like okay so chris is the one
that's not married here
anymore right he doesn't have a partner
like how would you guys
introduce a woman into this home and
then they were like well she'll just
have to
like lizzie ended up saying well we
already have so many people in this
household like in this family that
adding one more person wouldn't be a big
deal it's just that they have to be able
to
put up with us right now we're like gel
with our ecosystem i mean here
i feel like if i were to sit down for
you know a job interview
with his family i would like not it's
too much it might be too much
to sign up for all that because you want
to date the one person right but no
for this situation you have to be part
of the whole thing
the village man i bet i barely learned
all your guys's names right yeah
how did you just take one and run away
um
one kid or one no if you're dating like
right and you go
instead of you want to join my family
it's pretty simple
no okay so the reasons so hello um
we just chill it's just the mom over
here you know the reason why they're all
staying together
and it's just easier and it's just gels
well it's because of the
of lucas the little boy that has
autoimmune disease
and so they're all like working together
to
take care of him and they said that they
have already been like in isolation for
two years
even before quarantine stuff because of
his sensitive autoimmune disease like
his
his immune system is so so so
sensitive and weak that like they're
just mega careful to make sure he
doesn't get sick at all and that's the
reason why
this situation just works perfectly for
them so then they don't have to separate
the families and jump
kids from house to house so it just
works if you think about it though
this is pretty sweet because you have so
many people taking care of each other
and keeping each other company
and like it's the best case scenario for
lindsay
yeah and lindsay only no the kids too
well
i mean i'm thinking about the guys right
and well mike he gets to [ __ ]
but does the other guy care i don't
think he cares
he looks like a fuckless kind of guy
honestly if you look at his face
he could live without bugs he looks like
ooh [ __ ]
not for me like i was gonna say he's
like i'm done i've had babies i'm tired
you know like he looks like that kind of
guy he's also super nice to be like
welcome welcoming everyone into their
house but he also gets to be like
hey man [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my
house then oh no he has all the power
yes that's the power but now they're all
on the mortgage they
they pitched in money so they decided to
keep it going
yeah exactly this looks like the guy
that's like you guys gonna [ __ ] can i
listen
hey guys are you guys gonna go [ __ ] all
right cool i'm ready
[Laughter]
goodness
[Music]
so
you